I wrote it.
- She sent it.
- I'm ****ed
- So I was out one night
with a bunch of friends and I
ran into my ex-boyfriend
with this, like,
basic blonde looking girl.
- Very, very basic.
- She was not cute, right?
- And, I wasn't there.
- Right, she wasn't there.
- I'm always there.
- Then I get home and I'm like
"Okay, you know what, like
I'm actually a little upset.
Like, why did I not say hi?"
- You're like drunk, it's
three in the morning and
meanwhile I'm asleep
and you just wake me up.
- I'm typing it all out.
I'm like "It was really
weird to see you out, like,
I don't think we
should be friends."
Probably the opposite of
what I actually wanted.
- It was obviously the
opposite of what you wanted.
I tell her all the time,
like, you do not text an ex.
Especially when you're drunk.
Especially when it's
three in the morning.
Always ask me.
- But you didn't care.
I was like crying and
then I'm just like
okay I don't need you.
- I don't need no man.
- You always need
me and you know it.
- Okay that's probably true.
So I press send.
Like, what is he gonna say?
- And he texts her
back and it says-
- All good.
- Who does that?
- I send like this,
like this essay.
And then I get like that.
- And then he sends this.
- Now I have to send
another text and like
dig myself out of this.
- You gotta dig yourself
out of the hole.
Obviously when you do
something like that,
and then you're
like "I'm f***ed."
- Right and it was...
- You gotta unf**k it.
- You know what, just
like, forget what I said.
I was a little emotional.
I also had to admit defeat
and like I'm emotional.
- Like, okay, I'm
a little psycho.
- Right, so I'm like
"Okay like you know just
forget it ignore
it, like whatever."
- And then what'd he say back?
- He said "No worries."
- Period.
- Pro-tip.
- Twin knows best.